p could equal negative 2, or 1 4th, excellent effort if you got that one
correct. First we distribute the p then we subtract 2 from both sides. The
negative 2 does not have any liker terms. So we have 4p squared plus 7p minus 2
equals 0. We look for our greatest common factor, and the only common factor
between these three is 1. So we can't factor anything out. Now I want to find
factors of negative 8 that add to 7. The two factors are 8 and negative 1, they
multiply to give us negative 8 and they sum to give us 7. These two factors
allows to rewrite our middle term and then we can use factoring by grouping. We
continue factoring our equation by factoring a p by the first group of terms,
and a 2 from the last group of terms. Next we said each of these factors equal
to 0. P could equal 2 or p could equal 1 4th. These are our solutions.